[Music]
we live in a country that has incredible
abundance but if you were to add up all
of the hungry people in Los Angeles
County and it's contiguous counties as
well you'd have a state of hunger the
size of New Mexico or West Virginia two
and a half million people to me it is a
mandate for us to do better around this
and it's so simple it's just sharing
abundance my name is rick timaeus i'm
founder and executive director of food
for word our mission is to recover fresh
produce that would otherwise go to waste
and get it to people in need we started
in 2009 and it really was just walking
around my neighborhood and seeing all
these fruit trees dripping with citrus
that I realized that with a few
volunteers there might be a project here
that I could help facilitate eight and a
half years later and 43 million pounds
later here we are
[Music]
we have fed over one and a half million
people this year we have three programs
backyard harvest literally going into
folks homes who have agreed to have us
in there taking excess produce from
their trees sometimes their Gardens the
second program that was added a couple
years later was farmers market recovery
were at about 24 farmers markets every
single week with volunteer teams and
then the big one is the wholesale
recovery which works kind of under cloak
of darkness we get up super early
usually before the Sun even comes up and
are out there with our trucks gathering
pallets and entire truckloads of food
that is perfectly viable but for
whatever reason without otherwise end up
in a trash dump we're looking at things
that just might have a slight
discoloration or a slight bruise on them
it still has weeks left to its life but
it's not perfect and that's where we get
called
[Music]
we have learned that that hunger hides
in plain sight here in society there
should be no shame around it
unfortunately there is but the more that
we bring abundance out and really give
people food with dignity and give them
quality healthy nutritious food these
issues will slowly go away
[Music]